pediatric coronavirus cases you know
they're growing every week but with
at-home tests arriving from the
government this week some of you may
even have them there are some hopes this
will prevent the spread bianca holman
joining us live to explain bianca good
morning
good morning so have you got yours yet
well if you put in your order last week
you should be receiving your at home
proven 19 rapid test in the mail this
week so these tests are really important
for everybody especially families right
now because parents they can do them at
home with their children they give you
the results in minutes compared to the
pcr test there's a growing part of the
population who needs to be tested right
now
there was a 78 nationwide increase in
child covet 19 cases in the first week
of january compared to the prior week
that's according to the american academy
of pediatrics and children's hospital
association doctors say certain kids are
more at risk if your child has asthma or
any underlying respiratory issue they
could end up in the hospital if they
catch covet
children less than five years of age
were noticing that in particular with
omicron
it's been settling in the upper
respiratory tract
and infants and children usually have
some narrow passages and so as a result
they easily
can get
some nasal obstruction as well as a
creepy cough
so now the rapid test doesn't always
pick up asymmetric infections especially
with the omicron variant so doctors say
if the test reads negative but your
child was exposed to covet wait 48 hours
and conduct and conduct the test again
so in the next half hour we're going to
talk about some ways to of course
protect your child from covid and and
also how to properly administer the
chest with your child reporting live
bianca holman live local now